we've let the drug war demonize
recreational use
sounds frivolous and dangerous and
reckless and irresponsible but it's
really not and I think the rave movement
is sort of a antidote to the fact that
for many people the religious rituals
that they have just don't work and so
we've had to create our own in 82 I came
out to study with Stan Grof and
Christina Groff at Esalen and somebody
came to the month-long workshop with
MDMA and at first I was unimpressed the
way they described it because I thought
it's not the the bells and whistles and
the whole Lightning and all this for
Millis tea or anything it was just
quietly helps you to talk to each other
and feel your emotions and I was like I
feel fine they're ready what I need it
for but I thought I should buy some
anyway and give it a try so I tried MDMA
with my girlfriend and it was just a
revelation about how profound it is and
at the same time I realized that it was
starting to be sold as ecstasy so I and
it was also the rise of the Nancy Reagan
just say no so I knew that it was
inevitably going to be crushed but there
were quite a number of psychologists
psychiatrists other therapists using it
kind of as a catalyst for therapy in
this late 70s early 80s it was not an
approved drug but it wasn't illegal
either so in 84 I started a non-profit
before Maps that was the whole community
together the the therapists and the
researchers and and so we had a chance
where it was legal to try to build a
base of support and witnesses for a
potential legal case and that's where I
contacted Robert Mueller at the United
Nations the assistant secretary-general
and he helped me to meet a lot of
religious professionals who I sent MDMA
to and they tried it in monasteries and
all these places and and so we ended up
in - in 1984 the DEA moved to
criminalize MDMA and so we I went to
Washington and filed for an
administrative law judge hearing which
to our utter astonishment we won and the
judge said that MDMA should stay in
schedule 3 it should be illegal for
non-medical use but therapists and
psychiatrists should be
able to have it available to their
patients but then the DEA administrator
overruled that and put it in schedule
one so that's where I started maps in 86
and the idea was that there is no way
but through the FDA
that the drug war is too powerful but
maybe through science and medicine we
can make some progress right now there's
four main streams of psychedelic
research going on
one is MDMA for post-traumatic stress
disorder and I think that will be the
first through the system MDMA is more
gentle people don't have panic reactions
so much our first day that we completed
and published was with mostly people
with childhood sexual abuse or rape they
all had to have had therapy and
medications before and not not been
helped adequately among the people that
I'm got the MDMA with therapy basically
83% had a good clinical response versus
25% with the therapy only by the end of
2021 we're hoping that MDMA would be a
prescription medicine the other stream
is psychedelics for end-of-life people
tend to be more scared of dying than
they are of drugs so if we can show that
with drug assisted psychotherapy we can
help the dying process people are
willing to listen I think that's really
important we haven't touched their
disease process they still experience
the pain they're still dealing with the
fact that they're going to leave their
loved rundt ones or their children in
some cases these are parents of kids who
are who are young that sadness is still
there but there's also a larger framing
of that and so it's very touching and
then the third strand is psychedelics
for the treatment of addiction we
decided to tackle a cigarette smoking
addiction we've treated 13 people today
most of whom are completely abstinent
from smoking after their first
psilocybin session and then the fourth
strand of research is psychedelic
neuroscience to really understand
consciousness and understand how the
brain functions an analogy that you
could use to describe how the drug
effects
brain activity is either to say that
brain activity becomes relatively
disordered disorganized in the state
another thing that you could say is that
it's not entire disorder that rather
it's more like the brain enters more
kind of anarchic state and perhaps the
the most interesting finding is that the
the frontal cortex that perhaps the
command and control center of the brain
diminishes is activity and other other
brain areas take control and this is the
way how stored information that's not
usually available to consciousness
starts reaching consciousness MDMA is
terrific for a couples therapy for just
relationships now we're having a
difficult relationships not a disease
that's why we're not doing we have to
focus on diseases for political reasons
to try to get drugs through the FDA but
I think we would have a lot more happy
people and a lot more successful
relationships if people were assisted
with MDMA to talk to each other and to
acknowledge and listen better if this is
in fact something that can help a lot of
people and the we're at this stage of
the research which is you know at least
20 years behind where it would be if
people if it had been guided only by
science and not by politics and fears
and other forces that's really actually
a travesty so there's a growing
consensus among scientists that drug
laws and prohibition around psychedelic
drugs is irrational it's unhelpful maybe
it'll be like the forty years in the
desert you know we're the at the end of
the forty years maybe I'll finally have
the opportunity to become a legal
psychedelic therapist in the promised
land in the promised land and in the
glorious future where psychedelics are
integrated and people are balanced and
we're not so scared people different
than us and people are have shifted from
fundamentalism to sort of direct
spirituality and people look at the drug
war as one of the worst policies in the
history of America and we think now
let's party
I shouldn't say that breakfast